[Music]
the backlash about Kylie Jenner's
skincare just keeps coming fans up at
the 21 year old on blast / claims that
her recently dropped line of skincare
products are vegan just check out her
site there's a vegan banner on almost
every page and in the About section it
says quote everything is cruelty free
vegan gluten free paraben and sulfate
free and suitable for all skin types but
some haters were all not so fast
claiming Kylie skin isn't actually vegan
after a closer look at the ingredient
list people noticed that some of them
appear to be derived from animals
the vanilla milk toner includes an
ingredient called squalene and oil
that's usually sourced from deep-sea
sharks in the South Pacific on top of
that it smells like vanilla milk that
alone makes me want to put it all over
my face every night another person
thought there was an ingredient called 3
hydroxy a Stephan on in her toner and
face wash that comes from beavers and
others thought some of our products
contain glycerin which comes from animal
fats my face wash has Kiwi seed oil
which has vitamins C and E it really
makes your face feel like wow but the
answer is in the details when it comes
to vegan skin care guys a lot of these
ingredients can also be derived from
plants for starters while squalene is
derived from sharks it also comes in a
natural just as effective form squalene
which is harvested from various plants
olives rice bran and sugar cane and the
person who said 3 hydroxy a Stefano
comes from beavers didn't realize that
kylie's products actually contain
hydroxy Sven owned which is totally
different and said to be a clean safe
lab synthesized in nature identical
compound also while glycerine is
animal-based the ingredient in Kylie's
product is called glycerin which is
vegetable based that's a lot of drama
over nothing am i right but this isn't
the first time kylie has been dragged
for her skincare line the beauty mogul
caught a lot of
because her face scrub contains walnut
shells which are said to cause scrapes
on her skin and do way more harm than
they do good then fans criticized the
way she washes her face after she shared
this 40 second clip to social media
demonstrating how she uses her foaming
face wash
first fans were mad she didn't tie her
hair back and I totally get that like
what are we doing here Kylie but they
also weren't impressed that's used a
filter on the video that she used a
dirty towel with makeup on it to dry her
face and that she only washed her face
for a hot second of course Kylie's big
sister Kim jumped in to defend her
posting a series of light-hearted videos
on the Kylie cosmetics Instagram stories
honey do a ceasefire and unless you
think environment in thinking Kim also
use snapchats baby filter joking that
her skin had been totally transformed
alright so after that 10-second face
wash tutorial this is now what I look
like I am such a youthful complexion now
I got luck okay guys I think it's time
we lay off Kylie she's killing it and I
personally cannot wait to try Kylie skin
vegan or not if I can get my hands on it
cuz it is sold out of course we'll be
here to keep you up to date on all
things Kardashians and Jenner's so be
sure to keep it locked on ET until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]